♪ ♪
>> Jesse: THE LACKLUSTER
DEMOCRATS RUNNING.
THE PERSON LEADING THE LATEST
POLL ISN'T ON THE BALLOT.
SURVEY SUGGESTS THAT IF
MICHELLE OBAMA WERE TENTATIVE
MEMORIES, SHE WOULD BE THE FRONT
RUNNER.
SHE IS WALLOPING THE COMPETITION
WITH 26% SUPPORT.
THE FORMER FIRST LADY HAS
REPEATEDLY RESISTING THE FLOOD
OF CALLS TO GET IN.
WHAT IS IT SAY ABOUT THE 2020
FIELD, DANA?
>> Dana: THEY ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO FIGHT IT OUT AMONGST
THEMSELVES.
MICHELLE OBAMA IS NEVER RUNNING
FOR OFFICE, PERIOD.
THERE WAS ANOTHER STORY THAT
CAME OUT TODAY THAT SAID MIKE
BLOOMBERG IS THINKING ABOUT
GETTING BACK IN THE RACE BECAUSE
HE SAID HE WOULD NOT GET IN THE
RACE OF JOE BIDEN WAS GOING
AROUND.
NOW HE BARELY MIGHT BE THINKING
THAT JOE BIDEN IS IN FREE FALL.
SO MAYBE HE'S GOING TO GET BACK
IN THE RACE.
BUT I ALSO HEARD THAT'S NOT
TRUE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: JUAN, WHAT DOES THAT
TELL YOU ABOUT JOE?
OTHER HIGH-PROFILE CANDIDATES
WAITING IN THE WINGS.
HILLARY LAST WEEK, PEOPLE WERE
TALKING ABOUT HER.
WHAT DOES IT SAY TO YOU?
>> Juan: I DON'T LIKE IT SAYS
MUCH ABOUT THE FIELD.
I READ SOMEWHERE PEOPLE WERE
TALKING ABOUT OBAMA,
PRESIDENT OBAMA, COULD RUN AGAIN
AND WHAT IS THE LAW?
DO YOU MEAN THIS SAYS NOTHING
ABOUT THE FIELD.
AS DANA SAYS, SHE'S NOT RUNNING.
SHE IS A CULTURAL FIGURE.
SHE'S NOT BEYONCE BUT SHE'S
GETTING CLOSE.
I'M REPEATING SOMETHING I SAID
EARLIER.
SHE WENT ON HER BOOK TOUR AND
SHE FILLED ARENAS.
THEY WERE SOLD OUT ARENAS.
>> Greg: WHO DOES THAT SOUND
LIKE?
>> Juan: HE WISHES.
>> Jesse: TOPIC, JUAN.
>> Juan: THE LARGER ISSUE IS
THAT PEOPLE ARE STILL COMING TO
SOME CONCLUSION.
YOU SEE THIS IN THE POLLS NOT
JUST IN NEW HAMPSHIRE BUT
NATIONALLY.
PEOPLE SHIFT BETWEEN FIRST
CHOICE, SECOND CHOICE, NOT SURE.
THE BIG BENEFICIARY SO FAR AS
ELIZABETH WARREN WHO'S BEEN
TAKING SUPPORT AWAY FROM
PETE BUTTIGIEG, KAMALA HARRIS,
BERNIE SANDERS.
>> Jesse: I THINK IT SPEAKS TO
THE WEAKNESS OF JOE BIDEN.
>> Emily: AND DEMOCRATS IN
GENERAL.
THE GRASS IS GREENER ON THE
OTHER SIDE WE SAW IN 2016 WHEN
THEY WERE PINING AFTER JOE BIDEN
BECAUSE I FELT HE AT THAT TIME
BETTER REPRESENTED THE OBAMA
ERA.
HE WASN'T GETTING BEATEN UP IN
THE PRIMARY.
>> Dana: HE SHOULD'VE RUN
THEN.
>> Emily: NO MATTER WHAT CYCLE
IT IS, THERE IS ALWAYS GOING TO
BE PINING FOR WHOEVER IS NOT
THERE.
>> Greg: THEY ARE WISHFUL FOR
MICHELLE.
I CALL IT MICH-FUL THINKING.
WE HAVE SAID THIS.
THERE'S A TERMINAL LACK OF
EXCITEMENT ABOUT THE BIG NAMES.
MEANWHILE THE MOST GENUINE
PEOPLE YOU ARE NOT HEARING
ABOUT.
TO ME MARIANNE WILLIAMSON IS THE
MOST GENUINE PERSON UP THERE.
I THINK YANG LOST HIS BANG.
IF THEY GO AFTER JOE, I MIGHT
FEEL LIKE PICKING ON GRAMPS.
THEY MIGHT LET HIM WANDER OFF
INTO THE SUNSET.
>> Dana: IS ANYONE GOING TO BE
BRAVE ENOUGH TONIGHT?
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW.
MAYBE HUNTER COULD RUN.
HE'S VERY QUALIFIED.
>> Jesse: THE BIG DEBATE
TONIGHT.
HONESTLY THEY'RE GOING TO BE
ASKING ABOUT HUNTER.
BERNIE'S ATTACK AGAINST LIZ
WARREN FOR SUPPORTING
CAPITALISM.
HOW DO YOU SEE THINGS SHAKING
OUT?
>> Dana: BERNIE SAYS HE'S
GOING TO TAKE AROUND.
HE SAYS I'M NOT A CAPITAL S AND
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE A FIGHT
ABOUT CAPITALISM AND THAT WILL
BE REALLY GREAT FOR THE
DEMOCRATS IN THE GENERAL
ELECTION.
HERE'S ONE THING ABOUT BIDEN, IF
YOU ARE TO BE ABLE TO GET
THROUGH THIS PRIMARY PROCESS AND
BECOME THE NOMINEE, IT'S MUCH
BETTER TO HAVE HAD TO DEAL WITH
THE HUNTER SITUATION IN THE
PRIMARY THAN IN THE GENERAL
ELECTION BECAUSE THEN, BY THEN
THEY WILL BE BAKED INTO THE
CAKE.
>> Greg: WELL DONE.
AT THE END OF THE DAY.